من رام الله ينضم الينا مدير مكتب الجزيره
وليد العمري وليد مطالبات نتنياهو بوضع
الخلافات جانبا بين المؤسسه العسكريه
والسياسيه هل تلقى اصداء
ايجابيه لا تلقى ايه اصداء لان نتنياهو
متهم من قبل كل معارضيه وربما من داخل
حزبه ايضا بانه هو من اوعز بشن ذاك الهجوم
اللفظي عالي الصوت على رئيس هيئه الاركان
وان الوزراء ريجف وام سالم من حزب الليكود
الذي يقوده وكذلك الوزيران سموتريتش وبن
جفير من الصهيونيه الدينيه وعظمه يهوديه
وهما وهما حزبان عنصران متطرفا قد تحركا
بايعاز منه وان الامر كان مدبرا مسبقا
لذلك لا احد يثق بدعوات نتنياهو
ل للتوقف عن هذه الهجمات خلال الاجتماع
المذكور للطاقم الوزاري الامني المصغر
الذي كان يوم الخميس الماضي ليلا والذي
استمر لثلاث ساعات ونصف الصوت والصراخ
تعالى وايضا التشبيح بالايادي لدرجه ان
المعلومات المتسربه تتحدث عن ان بيني جانس
الذي لا يفقد اعصابه كان قد صرخ على
نتنياهو بصوت عال وطالبه بالدفاع عن رئيس
هيئه الاركان لكن نتنياهو فضل اما السكوت
امام الهجوم الذي يشنه اتباعه ومقرب او ان
وكل ما فعله هو ان يؤنب رئيس هيئه الاركان
ويطالبه بالاصغاء ل انتقادات واسئله
الوزراء وانهاء الجلسه لذلك نتنياهو لا
يثقون بما يقوله في سواء كان ذلك على
مستوى الساسه او الشارع الاسرائيلي او حتى
على مستوى داخل حلفائه هذا من ناحيه من
ناحيه اخرى المظاهرات التي خرجت في
اسرائيل امس وكانت في حيفا وكسار
قباله فيلا نتنياهو هناك وكذلك في تل ابيب
على مقربه من مجمع قياده الاجهزه الامنيه
والجيش و وزاره الدفاع ورئاسه الوزراء
وايضا في القدس الغربيه على مقربه من منزل
ال نتنه فيها جميعها رفعت شعارات تطالب
بتنحيه واقاله نتنياهو واقاله حكومته
واستبدالها بحكومه اخرى وان كانت قد جاءت
هذه المظاهرات في محاوله لاثاره قضيه
الاسرائيليين المحتجزين الاسرى في قطاع
غزه والتي تفاعلت وزاد فيها الغضب اثر
اعلان كتائب القسام عن ان هناك اربعه
اسرائيليين بينهم شاب عربي يعمل في مزرعه
والثلاثه الاخرون جنود قد قتلوا في قصف
اسرائيلي على سقه خان يونس هذا اثارهم
ورفعوا شعاراتهم من جديد بضروره وقف هذه
الحرب بشكل تام وابرام صفقه تبادل شامله
حتى لو اضطرت في اطارها اسرائيل للافراج
عن كافه الاسرى الفلسطينيين كي يحمون
اسراهم والمحتجزين في قطاع غزه هذا من
ناحيه من الناحيه الاخرى القلق الذي يساور
ذو ال يساور ذوي المحتجزين والاسرى في
قطاع غزه هو نابع بالاساس من ان استمرار
العمليات البريه والقصف الاسرائيلي غير
المحدود على مواقع متفرقه في قطاع غزه
يعرض حياتهم للخطر لذا قامت الشرطه بتل
ابيب بقمعهم واعتقلت اثنين منهم وهو ما
يشير الى ان ثقه هؤلاء وكانوا بالالاف
بالقياده السياسيه الاسرائيليه على وجه
الخصوص هي ثقه ان مهزوزه ان لم تكن معدومه
بالكامل وانهم لا يرون ان حكومه نتنياهو
تضع اعادتهم على راس اولوياتها وان
الجيش وايضا الحكومه يريدون الاستمرار في
هذه الحرب حتى لو استغرقت عاما كاملا مثل
ما
اعلن رئيس هيئه الاركان وايضا الناطق
العسكري وا ومن اجل محاوله تبديد التوتر
الداخلي في الحكومه الاسرائيليه او في
الاروقه السياسيه الاسرائيليه والذي يرى
كثيرون في اسرائيل نتنياهو وجماعته
يحركونه بهدف القاء التهم وتحميل
المسؤوليه عن الفشل الذريع امنيا
استخباراتيا وعسكريا في السابع من اكتوبر
اي بدايه عمليه طوفان الاقصى والحرب
الاسرائيليه على غزه والتي تدخل يومها ال3
اليوم ان هذه الثقه اصبحت شبه معدومه وان
نتنياهو انما يصوب سهامه على رئيس هيئه
الاركان والقياديه الامنيه العسكريه
للتنصل من مسؤوليته عندما تنتهي الحرب
ويتم فتح لجنه تحقيق وما جرى في الطاقم
الوزاري الامني المصغر المعروف بالكابينه
قبل ثلاثه ايام من صراخ ومن تشبيح
بالايادي وتبادل للاتهامات وتوجيهها ضد
رئيس هيئه الاركان يرى كثيرون انه بروفا
فقط او مقدمه لما سيكون عليه الحال عندما
يتم انشاء لجنه التحقيق الرسميه بعد
انتهاء هذ هذه الحرب وهذه الحرب يؤكد
الاسرائيليون على كافه مستوياتهم بانها
حتى الان لا تحقق انجازات استراتيجيه
تقربهم من الاهداف المعلنه والتي عاد
عليها نتنياهو امس وهي القضاء على القدرات
السلطويه والعسكريه لحركه حماس
واستعاده المحتجزين في قطاع غزه و وضمان
او توفير امن او جعل قطاع غزه لا يشكل
خطرا على منطقه غلاف غزه بانهم لم يحققوا
تقدما بهذا الاتجاه حتى الان الضابط
الاسرائيلي الذي اعلن عن مقتله الليله
الماضيه هو برتبه مقدم وقد قتل في
اشتباكات في شمالي القطاع وهو خامس ضابط
بهذه الرتبه العاليه الذي يقتل منذ بدايه
الحرب على غزه في معارك في قطاع غزه احدهم
قتل في معركه في اشتباكات على الحدود مع
لبنان شكرا لك من رام الله مدير مكتب
الجزيره وليد العمري